hey guys so I wanted to share with you
this behind the scene footage of this
event that I went to not too long ago
for Nintendo and I actually well we got
there I didn't know what it was gonna be
I just thought it was some fun event to
get to check out the new 3ds before it
came out well it turns out that this
said shoot was for a TV commercial I had
no idea so I wanted to share with you
guys the actual TV commercial I put a
link in the description of two of them
you may recognize some other youtubers
also in the commercial so I'm kind of
like freaking out right now we're at
this really fun event with Nintendo and
we just got to play hands-on with the
new Nintendo 3ds also Jimmy is exposing
these are amazing ok so here it is new
Nintendo 3ds
cartridge slot is now moved to my
amazing
this is our little Zelda room we got to
play majora's mask and it was really
freaking awesome
you guys are gonna be super impressed
with the 3d because it really does I'm
sorry Finn you shot the eye tracking is
actually pretty impressive because I'm
skeptical but then when you like move
your 3ds around it still stays in 3d I'm
told me and probably show up here I was
like I'm not gonna know anybody I'm not
gonna have any friends and guess what
you found friends what did you guys
think like what was your favorite part
about today Majora's Mask I really liked
that he also had a little Smash Brothers
tournament I came in second I came in
second to I won that we had to excited
about practice around and walk around
and of course I win the practice round
it doesn't count doesn't count no not at
all bye this is very exciting right this
is cool this is huge I can't fit all
this up for like 15 of us it's really
fun
what did you think of the three days
because I honestly never played three
days ever yes what do you think about it
on the new videos it works it doesn't
make me seasick yeah adjustable because
sometimes I feel like you can't handle
it all the way cranked up like a half
way yeah I'll get the 3d feeling and
it'll attract who was always watching
you it was crazy because as I was like
moving the GS I'm like this is actually
it's still saying in 3d a bullet bill
dog super smash prize Triforce toggles
not war fine thanks oh my god well I
don't I'm not even sure I want to get it
hope you guys enjoyed somebody's
behind-the-scenes clips
don't forget to check out the
commercials link in the description
below head on over there and leave some
comments that I sent you to go check it
out and if you see anybody leaving mean
comments about anybody in the videos or
any mean comments in general make sure
you reply back to the mean people saying
something nice okay I'll see you later
bye